here now with more Wisconsin Senator Ron
Johnson who is on the committee that put
out that report Senator I can't help but
but remember the the the political
hysteria that was how unaccompanied
minors were handled under the Trump
Administration now because of this
crisis you're saying it's possible that
adults are not vetted enough to know
what their criminal history might be yet
they get unaccompanied minors
they're not being vetted they've issued
a couple executive orders that have
basically relaxed the the types of
checks you do on on the people that
unaccompanied children being released
too we have the HHS whistleblower to
project Veritas talking about the the
being children being released into the
sex trade and you know it's been about
300 000 uncompanied children
since the by Administration took office
about 225 000 have been released to
sponsors we have no idea who they are we
don't track them whatsoever remember
when President Obama had his crisis it
was about 2 000 people a day Trump had
one month over 4 000 a day under the
body Administration it's over 7 000
people a day they don't even count it
call it apprehension anymore they called
encountered we're probably talking as
you were talking about about four
million people so far have you been
encountered process dispersed or come to
this country either as a known or
unknown God away uh it's completely out
of control by the way put that in
perspective 22 states have a population
less than 4 million people this is
completely out of control but the by
Administration apparently couldn't care
less they don't even call it a problem
they call it a challenge at most
what's the why uh that's to me always
the most revealing question so you had
Alexandria ocasio-cortez crying about
kids in cages because the Trump
Administration was intentionally making
sure that no child was released to
someone who wasn't able to be
responsible for them yet now it's tens
of thousands in the middle of the night
often with no background checks why if
there was such a crisis or was it just
hysteria what's the why for why they're
doing it this way now
you have to ask a President Biden you
have to ask Democrats who who vote to
not complete the wall that we already
paid for again enough people to that are
larger than the population of 22 States
um I I think it's pretty obvious I think
they they want to bring people in that
we're going to be beholden to them when
it comes to the next election even
though they can't vote of course that's
what they're always for mail-in
balloting as well without voter ID so I
think they've got a game plan here and
they're carrying out that game plan
is there anything Republicans on Capitol
Hill could can do I know the Senate
remains in the minority the the house
will be in in slim Republican hands if
there's one thing you could do that
would actually be effectual at this
point what would it be
well we have to keep raising the issue
when I was chairman of the homeland
security committee we had close to three
dozen hearings on some aspect of the
Border when the crisis was Far smaller
we've just written a letter to our
chairman who completely is unintered in
this I mean this is ranking member
Portman that led to this report the
majority has no interest whatsoever in
this crisis on the border so we just
need to ramp up pressure try and get the
mainstream media paying attention to
this because right now it's just oh it's
like Fox that are covering this so most
Americans don't even realize the
full-blown crisis occurring on a
southern border
you're exactly right there they seem to
be paying attention a little bit but
it's always what we need to spend more
money down there to process faster not
actually fix the problem Senator Johnson
thank you so much for your time tonight
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else